Mandy Moore and Milo Ventimiglia are so
good as husband and wife you would never
know that the first time they met is
when they read for the roles was the
chemistry between you and Milo immediate
he's such a special guy it's really not
hard to have to just love him I feel
very safe I feel very like protected
with him I've never really felt that
with somebody that I've worked with
before
ah so sweet so it's no surprise so many
fans want these two to date in real life
but Mandy's been dating rocker Taylor
goldsmith since 2015 and Milo says he is
not into the idea of dating a co-star
tonight's episode is heavy on the
relationship between Milo and Mandy's
Jack and Rebecca it's an episode that
takes place all in the past
and it's the back story for the day that
the the triplets are born so it's a
really interesting special episode in
that sense there are three human beings
inside of me jack and they're all lining
up to go down the waterslide we don't
have anything done for them yet
I read the script and I like
hyperventilated like Chrissy and I were
both like just like tears streaming down
ER like everybody was crying if I think
about it I'll cry right now
I saw a screening of it last week and I
almost had to excuse myself I'm like
Chrissy you know not to watch the
episode with anyone else around no you
mean to tell me I need to stock up and
have my stuff beside me around my
Kleenex beside me how many times can we
say that but it's it's the truth it's
the truth
[Music]